Let's start with the first expression. This one over here doesn't depend on sigma at all.
Hence, the derivative 0. The derivative of logσ is 1/σ.
And this expression is funky because you have a σ⁻² in the denominator.
That results to 1/σ³ and then -2 multiplied in cancels the minus 1/2 over here
very conveniently to with we have all these sigmas in the denominator.
We multiply up σ³ which gives σ² over here and leaves only this expression on the right side.
Taking out σ² to the left side, we observe that we have Nσ² in the sum.
We get Nσ² and bringing N to the right gives us σ.
This is the full proof that the empirical observed variance over the data
is the maximum likelihood estimator for finding the parameters of a Gaussian.
If you got this far, I am impressed.
We left basic statistics way behind us and got into fairly heavy math.
Thanks for taking this unit. If you just clicked forward and hit the next button, never mind.
You can complete the do you understand basic statistics
without understanding how it's being derived
Let's move on and use the Gaussian for something practical.